just this morning NASA's Instagram page
posted an incredible picture of Pluto
there it is it was taken by their new
Horizons spacecraft it's the most
detailed view of Pluto ever seen people
are really excited about the heart shape
which they can see on Pluto's surface
check it out it's right there and it's
already ya heart and Pete it's already
trending on Twitter now of course this
is not the first time we've seen random
shapes on planets that sort of look like
something familiar there was this
picture of Mars that some say looks like
some say looks like Coolio yeah
Uranus this one looks kind of like paul
blart on a segue there's this one on
Venus it looks like Calvin peeing on the
Yankees logo
there's this one if net queue that looks
like the Taco Bell dollar cravings menu
there's this video of mercury some
people say looks like an episode of
families views I don't see it myself
I've been staring at a paratha yeah yeah
and NASA just released a new image of
Pluto that unfortunately takes some of
the romance out of the earlier heart
photo I think it's just too bad when
things
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography